this week conflict zone is in Stockholm
to talk to Morgan Johansen Sweden
Minister of Justice and migration after
terror attack and increasing tension
Sweden debate its political future and
test its values as a Swedish model of
hospitality and integration reached its
limit
[Music]
male me Jonathan welcome to conflict
zone Islamophobia anti-semitism grows of
extreme right movement and parties
plenty of signs that the Swedish model
of tolerance has reached its limit
hasn't it
now I wouldn't phrase it like that well
you know there we have also of course
xenophobic parties that we have movement
in Sweden also in that sense but my
sense is that that kind of of feelings
and and poor and pointed in the
discussion that has actually peaked you
know there is a party of Sweden the
Sweden Democrats who grew they grew very
very fast
more or less twenty percent up to the
latest polls well they had they were
over twenty percent into that around
every fifth one in this country is ready
to give the voice to know hockey which
is a certain extent phobic and working
with these and of course a problem but
my point was that they grew very fast in
2015 when we had the big migration
crisis in Sweden a big migration after
that after that they have actually
stalled and they're still around twenty
percent but the big migration moment two
hundred thousand refugees in the last
two years more or less
well 163,000 in 2015 and another
diminished population and another 30,000
yes around two hundred thousand hundred
fifty years in these two last two years
the Swedish population is around ten
million again two hundred or two hundred
fifty thousand refugees in the last two
years this represents two percent of
your population what is the problem
well the problem was that that when
there was a lot of refugees coming to
Europe in 2015
Sweden and Germany and some other
countries but not as many
took a larger responsibility than any
others but that was in 2015 where we
received a hundred and sixty-three
thousand people but then till then I
have made a very opulent yes but may I
also may answer is yes but I have to add
two and a half seconds but may I ask
mayor answer question and hundred
sixty-three thousand came in 2015 then
we had to take measures to stem the flow
which we did border controls the ID
controls and also the new legislation so
after that last year we had 30,000 and
now we have a control over that
situation but it all comes down to the
problem that Europe does not take this
that issue as live a global speak about
Sweden extreme right membership is also
on the rise expo publication reported a
growth in membership that has translated
into more than 3000 events by the Nordic
resistance movement in 2016 yes and we
have something got better well well
we're not saying I am saying that we
have problem with some right-wing
extremist groups of course we have and I
think problems well ended in 2015 we
have problems with people trying to to
burn down the reception centers that was
112 fires last year
yes at refugee reception centre 16 yeah
so what's your point
I hardly I - I'm curious to listen to
your judgement of your own at least or
of your own country of these or
extremist groups which we of course need
to do combat in that in the sense by by
by by the police but I think it's not
sufficient isn't it well you always have
to prove that someone has done some
crime before you consent of them I mean
sweetness si it is a station now I that
anything about the society what's going
on in the society well none of the only
country
the other country is like also Germany
but especially also France have the same
problems
my question is only how do you judge the
danger of these cases also politically
well we have we actually we have always
had groups extremist groups like like
this in the recent years they have been
more active and that is a threat to well
to our to individuals but also in the
long run of course to the society so
it's a it is a problem of course it is
but we're doing what we can in order to
fight it let's talk about another
problem of violence in April a terrorist
attack with a truck killed killed five
people and injured 19 in central
Stockholm the perpetrator was in silence
seeker do you think there is a
relationship between your migration
policy and these terrorist acts well I
mean crime connected to asylum seekers
are very very few it is there is no
direct link like that but of course
that's in every country we've had
problems with people getting radicalized
in different ways and we have to be to
be vetted to to trace them as as as soon
as we can and also to to sentence them
for the crimes of them and then help me
with this vote after the attack your
Prime Minister himself condemned the
open-door policy he said Sweden will
never go back to the mass migration we
had in autumn 2015 never this was not a
quote about controls this is a principle
vote about migration policy why well in
2015 we when we had over 10,000 coming a
week of course then in that situation we
did not have control that's why we
introduced the idea controls or the
border controls and nowadays we have
that do you think
that your migration and integration
policy is on the right way
well after 2000 2015 crisis we have been
able to process most of all the
applications and they are now going out
on the street I'm a Swedish labour
market that is growing faster than most
other countries are doing is you are
seeing that our unemployment rate is
falling our state budget is in order
we actually have have have surfaces so
we are managing that but at the same
time we of course must be be very
vigilant on different extremist
activities both on the right wing side
but also on the inside but let's meet
let's be honest we know that the
migration crisis didn't end in 2016
there is now a certain impression that
the problem is not anymore
as actual but it is what happens what
will happen well if migrants will and
want to come back to Sweden to come to
Sweden well we're so we cannot go back
to 2015 situation it's the question of a
quantity well we cannot handle a
situation where we we already had
163,000 coming in one year and we still
have 60,000 waiting to get their
applications processed we cannot have a
situation where that goes I have to
learn them again if this statement do to
the controls it is it due to the number
it is suitable to the number in that
sense we cannot have a situation where
it went out of percent till now of a
population one of the richest countries
why this is too much because well we
don't have put this way I think on the
labor market I think I'm not that
concerned right now because we have a
very good at the developmental leg
market everyone even without it we have
100,000 available job
we have them and a decrease in the
unemployment rate so that's good but our
problem zero is in other sectors housing
is one of them we have to to be able to
build much more houses in order to to
get I'm going to get roof over people's
head and even though we're building now
more than we've done for 40 years still
I mean if we should have an inflow of
another let's say hundred thousand this
year
there could be absolutely no
possibilities of a house II were not due
to the migration crisis it is now it is
now because after when we all now have
processed all the applications now
they're getting out in the
municipalities and we have to have
housing and I understand the polling so
houses as one teachers you know is
another for the children and social
services so how many years do you need
to tell to the migrants in Africa
wherever now we are prepared for another
few of you now we haven't we haven't
shuttle borders there are still people
coming in to swim I think we have
between 400 and 500 people asylum
seekers each week coming to Sweden so
have a shuttle borders but we now have a
level which we can handle and we didn't
have that in two so let's speak about
migration in February riots broke out in
the neighborhood of rinkeby in Stockholm
mainly an immigrant community protesters
attacked the police destroyed property
and burnt cars how do you explain the
explosion of violence in Stockholm well
that is in many earth in many other
countries around the world I would say
effect of of that that people have been
excluded from from society they haven't
got gotten any job so haven't gone gonna
appropriate these people well if you
have if you have a long term long period
of time where people are not or not
getting into the labour market
sooner or later this will cause social
disturbances these people were not
asylum seekers but they were they were
people who have many of them have been
grown up in families where where they
have got that that at of them are
Swedish this is opportune oh yes most of
them I say many of them are born in
school most of them haven't gotten the
opportunities that they should have so
the issue here and the key here is the
ordinary things like access to education
and unemployment but all these event
approving that integration policy is not
very big success as you are saying
according to the stockholms national
statistics about 90% of the population
rinkeby are immigrants or have
backgrounds this is a typical
characteristic of a ghetto how could it
happen that cities in Sweden ended we
get one well I've been to the ghettos in
the United States and I also do not
compare that Irish ampair they do not
compare that I can wear them with elbows
and we're reading yes 90% of population
are you what to say I hear what to say
but I don't know if you visited any of
our areas have you yes yes yes if I have
I mean 90 percent of the population is
coming from a background which is a very
specific one a lot of unemployment a lot
of poor people a lot of people without a
big hope for future you just mentioned
it yes again what didn't work till now
in the migration others that do not
compare it to the ghettos in the big
American cities it is a completely
different so you speak about bodily
formula but you will but you do have if
there is I mean the point here is that
we need to have a better situation on
unemployment for instance and that's why
it is good now that we see we have a
prognosis came out yesterday I don't
know if you've seen that but just for
2017 and 2018 we will create create
150,000 new jobs
for most are located most but no most of
those people ate out of those a 12:10
out of these jobs will go to people
people who are born outside Sweden
according to the tube to the to the
prognosis so the labor market in Sweden
is very strong and it and these and the
people that will need this job can
benefit from it that's interesting
because among the immigrant population
unemployment statistics are saying
around 20% are coming from these groups
- among 4% Swedes what we are you doing
to close the get I think that the
numbers now is 16% or the PLO make it
better not 60% of those people who are
born outside Sweden is on unemployed 4%
are unemployed from the people who are
born in inside Sweden so that's the gap
which we have to get done but the thing
is now that when we now have a situation
where we have have had very high growth
rate in Sweden 4% growth rate in 2016
and another another three and a half
percent now I mean that means that the
new the new jobs are now coming there
and when the number of people who are
born is really good their unemployment
rate is very low
of course now next in line is the people
who are born outside Sweden that they
are also getting jobs yes but let us
continue to speak about what's going on
in this society a December in December a
report commissioned by Sweden sidled
contingencies agency spoke about the
growth and operation of the Muslim
Brotherhood in Sweden and claims that
the organization has been building
perilous social structures in Sweden
parallel structures yes and I mean
that's a a of course a very big problem
we're there when there are people who
are trying to to establish some of some
legal order of themselves I mean it's in
Italy that now it is loosely rather this
would has been in Swedish since the
seventies why this governmental others
didn't react as they have been in every
country in the European Union I would
say that the radicalization is clear yes
but that's why we for instance
criminalized the the action of going
abroad to to join Isis we criminalize
that a year ago and and I'd say by doing
so these kind of journeys as I'd say
almost stopped we've had 300 people
going there and 150 coming back but that
is not the case anymore but the ideology
of the Muslim Brotherhood is not only
the concern that terrorists are going to
Syria it's a question in the society and
of the radical radical ization or in the
society the author of the Demeter and we
don't ban we don't ban views but we've
an axe as if they are into any kind of
activities connected to terrorism of
course that's an issue for the police
but there is plenty of anecdotal
evidence that shows that the very
radical islam has roots in sweden in
august of last year there were reports
of muslim schools segregating children
according to gender women are discussing
about the behavior also in this question
what is the society reacting how is this
government reacting what are you doing
against all these problems well for
instance according to the schools it's
extremely important that we have a
surveillance of what are what are going
on in schools we cannot accept having an
abuse we cannot accept having a school
separating girls and it had the most and
that's why if that is the case then we
simply have to close down that school
when well we are well yes but when it
comes up then it's an ish
surveillance so let's talk about Samsung
weeks and they have the opportunity have
the possibility to close that yeah but
there is another issue work you would
answer I have to do let's talk about
anti-semitism there have been several
reports on anti-semitism attacks and
harassment in Sweden that the country
have problems with anti-semitism as such
I'd say many countries have but we take
it that very seriously also and of
course if we see anything any kind of
that entity that you had even the
Minister for Housing and Urban
Development whose compared Israel to the
Nazi Germany in your government you want
the name Bella Kaplan I know the guy but
I actually don't remember that fresh at
that is that's no I don't can you yeah
this was in between 14 and 16 was
Minister and he compared Israel to Nazi
Germany yes I I don't that I don't
remember that that phrase but as yours
as you will also know he he resigned
from though but again and Nazi nail
groups like the Nordic resistant
movement are targeting Jews in umeå in
Malmo yes and that and that's why we
have to fight that kind of right-wing
extremes when and why now and what did
you do till now things didn't get better
well I mean even you can tell you can
tighten the legislations as well as we
have done but I think that there is
there is always a risk that you that you
don't find everyone but we have to do of
course more and be a be ready to to to
strengthen the legislation to have found
one you are not only the Minister of
migration that you're also the news of
Justice recently you dropped charges of
rape against WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange after seven years it took some
of the country's brightest legal minds
seven years to figure out that there was
no case to bring forth
say no no no that was I mean the
situation was that he he flew from from
the country he did not want to stay in
Sweden nothing very listens he did not
want to stay in Sweden to be
interrogated so what we changed while so
I mean so the blame is on him
not on Sweden why did you need seven
years and now you are closing the case
well because first of all it's a
prosecutor that is that during this
investigation it's not a government
it's a prosecutor second I mean the
blame is on Julian Assange he decided he
decided he decided not to stay in Sweden
in order to - and in order to answer
questions about the other one one of
hell's the case because because we asked
him well you have to come to Sweden so
we can interrogate you that's the garage
suddenly came into the suspicious and
was being suspicious and now the way
they were certainly dropped is just as
suspicious
this looks like a head doesn't it no I
mean what is look what is looking bad
if the Dylan Assange did not want to
come to Sweden to explain and to be
interrogated that looks but he's a young
man he has time to come and the and the
justice in this country has time to wait
my question is why are you closing what
ugly the in the seventh year because the
prosecutor came to the decision that we
cannot proceed with with it we don't
getting any more information that's why
they did it
that's a prosecutor that's not about the
government that's not the government
decision it's a prosecutor but again the
question that would you that must must
be raised is to join Assange
why does him didn't he want to come to
Sweden to answer he's being languishing
in the Ecuadorian Embassy for five years
and now he faces charges for jumping
bail are you going to intervene on a
sauce behalf will you
the government does not interfere with
ongoing prosecution's it's not it's not
the way these things are dying this is
the legal authorities that sound like
this would you say that the accusation
to it as songs are really as serious as
I think I doubt the value that I just
I'm not saying that there are people
that has that has filed a there is an
ongoing there are people that have said
that I said that they have been victims
of wrongdoing victims of crime that
Julian Assange has committed that is
what they are saying thank you very
nicely and these are actually looking
very sad these people also actually have
the right to to be able to to be
vindicated and that's why we hold on the
whole system is working all these levels
and thank you very much for being in
conflict thank you thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]